and hello everyone thank you for being
here today you all know i'm automation
panda andy knight also pandy uh you can
check me out on twitter at
automationpanda automationpanda.com i'm
just google automation panel you'll find
me somewhere so today i'm going to be
talking about my favorite programming
language python
yay
awesome
uh what i'm going to demonstrate for you
today is a python project
using selenium webdriver this is
selenium comp
now many of you probably know i love to
use python for testing i think python is
one of the best languages for test
automation
i find it to be a fairly
accessible syntax
it does a lot of things for you it's
just nice to read
it has a lower learning curve than some
other languages like java and c-sharp
and javascript so it's it's easier for
folks who are new to not only automation
but new to programming to to get into um
and thankfully selenium webdriver has
python bindings along with java c-sharp
javascript ruby php
so i have this project here today and
i'll i'll dunk the link in the ch chat
as again to the github repository just
so everybody has it you can follow along
boom
so i'm not going to be giving a talk in
a traditional sense of like i'm going to
have slides i'm going to like walk
through concepts this is all going to be
hands-on i'm going to be walking through
this project with you together to show
how
i would structure
a a test automation project with
selenium webdriver in python
and what's really cool about today is
not only that but i'm going to be
showing how to do it with the screenplay
pattern um somehow you have to model
your interactions like when you log into
a page and you navigate and all that
stuff
you could make raw selenium blood driver
calls which is what a lot of like demos
and quick articles do
um
more commonly people will use page
objects where you have your locators and
your methods
to represent a page or component of a
page but i i strongly believe that
screenplay is a much better
pattern for modeling those interactions
and i in my previous projects
i've used um
or i should say in my my previous team
we developed a screenplay implementation
called boa constrictor but that was
a.net
recently i've done a very small
bare bones basic implementation of
screenplay in python which i will be
demonstrating for you today and this is
actually the first time i have publicly
shown
the python screenplay package
so let's dive in shall we
um
in the project here i've got it open in
visual studio code
um
fairly standard python projects
you put all it
uh i should i should also back up not
only are we using python with selenium
webdriver we're also using pi test
pi test is the most popular python test
framework it is not part of the standard
library it's a third-party package but
still it's it is
by
user share the most popular and it's
excellent it's you write your test as
functions you don't have to write big
hunky classes it has a really nice
reasonable way of handling something
cleanup called fixtures that we'll look
at in a second
so in a project when you are using pi
test as your framework you will put all
of your test cases under a folder called
tests
and so here i have a module named test
underscore search dot py and that's
what's shown here on the main screen
this is the main test case
everything will
come through here
pi test will search for
test modules
with
functions named test underscore or
something
treat those as tests line them up as
dominoes and run through them all
so in our test search module
we have some imports here which i'll
explain a little bit later
but our main test case
is this one testduck.gosearch
this is a plain old python function
and in it i have the basic steps of the
test case and i have them arranged in
the
arrange act assert pattern
i'm hoping y'all have heard of arrange
act assert it's it's a great way to
structure your test cases whether
they're used unit test cases or
end-to-end test cases they keep your
tests focused on individual independent
behavior if you're familiar with gherkin
or bdd or given when then given when
then is essentially a range active
search so this is how i structure all my
functional test cases
so in order to do a
or
the test i haven't explained what the
test is yet the test here what it does
is it performs a basic
search using duckduckgo duckduckgo is
the search engine just like google yahoo
bing whatever why'd i choose that one
because it had easy locators
truth be told
so what are the steps to a duckduckgo
search test
to set it up
we are going to
load
the search page
now there's this this thing here this
actor attempts to this is where the
screenplay pattern comes in uh in
screenplay pattern
like i said it's a pattern for
interactions
what i always like to say is in
screenplay actors use abilities to
perform interactions
right versus the page objects which are
you have pages with locators and action
methods
with screenplay we separate concerns
further actors use abilities to perform
interactions
the actor is the initiator of all the
interactions so i have an actor object
here and that actually came from a
fixture essentially a setup function
that was dependency injected here and
i'll show you what that looks like in
just a moment but just take it for
granted right now it's constructed in a
like a setup and given to us
so we have an actor
and anytime an actor wants to do two
tasks we say actor.attempts2
right because they're attempting to do
something we don't know if they're going
to be successful yet this is a testes so
actor attempts to perform an interaction
and so here the interaction is to load a
particular web page with a given url
so i have an interaction named load
it's called search page
and it passes the search page url
underneath of that selenium webdriver is
there selenium webdriver is an ability
because it in the ability of selenium
webdriver enables the actor in order to
load a page
and so the screenplay brings us all
together so i can have a very readable
step actor attempts to load search on
the page and that's my arrange
as part of the act portion of my test
actor attempts to what's the main action
what's the target thing what's the main
behavior being executed here
actor attempts to search duckduckgo for
a given phrase
right i could be searching anything it
could be
panda python parakeet whatever
that phrase is coming in through a
parameterization of our test case so
here
the pi test test case function is
literally just a plain old function with
test underscore in the front but i can
parameterize it
with different inputs so here i'm
parameterizing a phrase
i'm choosing three different search
strings panda python parakeet and i'm
injecting that into the test case so
that can be used here as a string
variable
so this test will actually run three
times because of this once for each
phrase so i'll be searching one time for
panda searching one time for python
searching one time for parakeet that's
also good
so then in the
once i do my main action i need to
verify that it was successful
so there's a couple assertions that we
want to do and that's all part of the
assert phase
so what do i want to check after i
do a search i expect
that
the result page is loaded has links and
all the good stuff so actor attempts to
verify result page input value is the
phrase
so at the top that input value is there
actor attempts to verify
result page title contains the phrase
that's the page title like in the tab or
whatever
and then finally actor attempts to
verify that the result links include
whatever my phrases i want to make sure
that when i search for panda i see links
for pandas and not for parakeets
so high level
we have our test case here this is
almost like reading plain english um
that's one of the powers of the
screenplay pattern
so let's
start to
actually let's let's run this real quick
just to show how it works and then we'll
dig a level deeper into our into our
project to see how this magic is
happening right because at a high level
you can see oh well these are words that
indicate things but how does the code
actually work so let's run the test
we can see right now it's set up using
chrome
so it's doing the test three times once
for each of those phrases and it is
pretty quick but you can see duckduckgo
the browser pops up talk to codepage
load navigate verifies and so i was able
to finish those three seconds for three
tests in about 10 seconds
pretty good local machine here
so
let's see what else
okay
um
so let's now dig deeper into uh what
is going on in this code
so uh let's look at the setup of what's
going on here
so as i said there was this actor that
gets injected
when you're using pi tests you do your
setup and your cleanup using something
called fixtures
a fixture is another function that will
build objects that you can call in the
signature of the test case functions and
pi test will automatically resolve that
and give that to you
so when it comes to things like your
webdriver object any inputs into
automation and this actor object for our
screenplay pattern we want to be able to
construct those using fixtures
we put those in a
a file called conf test dot py
this is the standard name i did not get
to choose this name pi test will look
for files of this name in the test
directory automatically and then use
that
so there are actually three things we
want to set up
there's the config the configuration for
our tests
there's the
browser which is going to be using our
selenium webdriver and then there's the
actor to use for screenplay
text out this real quick give some more
room
so
the config here is actually i something
i've created
um in the project directory in the root
level i have a file called config json
this is how i'm choosing to pass inputs
into my test automation right um things
like hey what browser do you want to use
do you want to test chrome do you want
to test firefox do you want to test
headless chrome right i want to be able
to specify that because all the tests
should run the same on any browser
also i'm tuning an implicit wait time
for selenium webdriver selenium we know
we can do implicit or explicit weights
since this is a small project i'm going
to be okay with an implicit weight if
this were something i'm trying to scale
i probably want to bake explicit weights
into my screenplay calls
so here i have this setup i like using
json with a python project because
the python standard library has a json
module that makes it really easy to read
and so back to comp test
my
config fixture which has session scope
meeting once for the entire test run
what it will do is it will open that
config json file and read the json data
into a python dictionary
beautiful two lines right here and i can
read that config file
then what i want to do is i want to make
sure that the values in that config file
are good because if there's a problem in
there you want to catch it before any
test run before you start wasting time
and resources executing
so i want to make sure that
my browser config
is one of the supported browsers
i want to make sure that my implicit
weight is an integer and that that
implicit weight is greater than zero if
that looks good what my
config
fixture will do is it will return that
dictionary so that tests can access it
and even other fixtures
so once i have my config
next thing i can do is i can use that
config to help build my webdriver object
so here we have another fixture called
browser you can see it takes in the
config
and what it does is it looks inside the
config to see hey what browser do you
want if you want firefox construct a
firefox driver if you want chrome
construct a chrome drive if you want
headless chrome construct a chrome
driver with headless options
otherwise if it's not recognized fail
then we're going to set the implicit
weight for that browser based on the
input we were given
and then we are going to not just return
the browser object but yield
yielding
is
in python if you're not familiar it
makes something called a generator
um when it comes to pi test fixtures
the way it works is anything before the
yield is like the setup portion
anything after the yield is the cleanup
portion because python execution will
automatically come back in here after
the end of the test and perform cleanup
operations so we've cons we've
initialized our webdriver yielded it
then automatically after the test we
want to come back here and quit our web
drivers so we don't have those zombie
processes
so then finally the third fixture we
have for setup is the actor that's that
screenplay thing the initiator of all
interactions
so the actor will need the browser and
how we create it is like this we say a
equals actor we create a new object we
could give him or her or a name we're
choosing not to
and then to add to inject the ability
for the web driver we say actor can use
and then pass it in
we're calling the ability browser and
we're giving it the the object with the
variable browser and then we're just
going to return that we don't need to do
any cleanup here
so that's how we do our setup very clean
we can use it for any test it's very
very reusable it's very nice
so here and again
so
when the test case called the actor
you know it it was doing that actor
setup but that required the web driver
so it would automatically do that by
dependency and then the web driver
needed the the configuration to be read
so it did that boom boom boom everything
comes through nicely
so now let's dig into our screenplay
calls here
so
uh
it
what i have done is i have actually
created a test library package up here i
create a test library because the tests
directory is not meant to be a python
package meaning no init no imports or
anything i put all my test slide in a
package that can be read this could be
in the same project and different
project whatever
but i have
two things i have interactions and pages
um
let's start with pages typically if
you're familiar with page object model
you might think like you have classes
with locators and action methods
when you use screenplay the recommended
practice is that you will still have
page classes
but only for modeling structure not for
performing interaction and so what i've
done here in this class is i have
created a search page
and a result page
and they have nothing but
locators
and possibly a url
so here my search page the i want to
model the search input field so i create
a locator it's a tuple with the type of
locator as well as the query for it so
i'm getting this by id
result page i have two locators one's a
css selector one is an id
and so i can call these universally i
don't have to construct a page object
and inject the webdriver it's just these
are essentially kind of like static
classes you could almost think of um
universal accessible created one time
you don't have to create duplicate
instances of it and these are meant to
be incredibly declarative you know they
just model structures so that our
interactions can use these locators
we hop over to the interactions class
this is where we start constructing some
of those
those those tasks that we saw in the
main test case
so for example
when we said actor attempts to load the
web page here's the load task
um what it does is it it is
part of the python screenplay package
this this task comes from a screenplay
or from screenplay pattern import task
so we make a subclass of task
and actually it's
it's it actually in python is snapshot
class nevermind so it's class um what we
do is we want to
uh when we construct this class we want
to pass in a target url so that's saved
as an instance variable
and then every task implements this
performance method it gets injected with
the actor and so from the actor we can
then get the
webdriver
object
using the browser ability and then we
can make standard selenium calls with
the browser so things like browser.get
and so that's ultimately what's
happening under the hood it's just a
little bit more verbose little little
more self-documenting
or for example my search duckduckgo task
i passed in a phrase
inside the perform as i got the browser
object the webdriver object and then i i
did browser find element for
that search page search input there's
that locator from that page class
and then search input send keys i type
the phrase and hit enter and that's how
search was performed so you can see how
we can construct these these
interactions these tasks
um
to do things with screenplay pattern
um then i have my other tasks here you
know verifying the result page whatever
stuff you know make performing
assertions in these tasks here um i also
have a different kind of interaction
called a question that will um whereas
the task will just do something a
question will return a value
so here like if i want to get the input
value of something you know i can find
an element get its value attribute and
return it
or if i want to get the title of the
page i can return browser.title um
right now the python screenplay package
here is very barebones um in in the
c-sharp implementation i worked on boa
constrictor we actually provided
out-of-the-box interactions to ask some
questions for basic web driver things
like do you want to get the text of an
element do you want to get value do you
want to click it um i we haven't done
that yet in python all we have is core
screenplay so all of things all the
basic things like this input value of
text list for title load those should
all be things that would be in a python
screenplay package given to you you
shouldn't need to implement those what
you would need to implement would be
your custom tasks like search.go or
verify your result page input
so
yeah so in a nutshell that is how
you would construct a python test
automation project in python with pi
test using this